>>> THIS JUST IN TO CNN,
DISGRACED SING, R. KELLY HAS
EN SENTENCED TO 30 YEARS IN
PRISON.
HE WAS CONVICTED OF NINE COUNTS,
INCLUDING RACKET TIERING AND SEX
TRAFFICKING CHARGES.
>> JEAN CASAREZ JOINS US OUTSIDE
THE COURTHOUSE.
GET US UP TO DATE.
WHAT DID YOU HEAR.
>> Reporter: FIRST OF ALL, THE
SENTENCING GUIDELINES ALLOWED TO
BE SENTENCED UP TO LIFE IN
PRISON, SOS IN 30 YEARS, AND R.
KELLY IS 55 YEARS OLD RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, THERE WERE SEVEN
VICTIMS THAT STOOD UP IN COURT
AND GAVE VICTIM IMPACT
STATEMENTS TODAY.
THEY WERE ALL VERY EMOTIONAL.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO DIRECT SOME
OF THEIR TALKING TO R. KELLY IN
GENERAL.
THERE WAS ONE VICTIM THAT SAID I
WAS SEXUALLY EXPLOITED 23 YEARS
AGO, AND AS THE YEARS WENT ON, I
KEPT WONDERING WHY IS NOTHING
HAPPENING HERE.
AND THEN SHE TURNED TO R. KELLY
AND SHE SAID, NOW YOU'RE GOING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
NOT HAVE YOUR FREEDOM.
ANOTHER VICTIM SAID THAT SHE
TRULY HOPES THAT ALL CAN MOVE ON
FROM THIS, AND SHE PRAYS TO GOD
THAT PEOPLE CAN HEAL.
ANOTHER VICTIM STOOD UP WITH HER
FATHER AT THE PODIUM, AND SHE
SAID, MY FATHER WAS SEXUALLY
ABUSED WHEN HE WAS YOUNG AND HE
DIDN'T SEXUALLY ABUSE ME.
NOW, THAT WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE
MITIGATING FACTORS THAT THE
DEFENSE ACTUALLY PUT ON.
THERE ARE DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN UNSEALED IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS RELATED TO THE SEXUAL ABUSE
THAT R. KELLY HAD WHEN HE WAS 6
YEARS OLD.
IT'S ALLEGED IN THOSE DOCUMENTS
THAT FAMILY MEMBERS, OTHERS,
FAMILY FRIENDS STARTED SEXUALLY
ASSAULTING AND ABUSING HIM FROM
6 ONWARD.
ONE RELATIVE EVEN BEGAN TO TAKE
PICTURES OF HIM.
THE DEFENSE USED THIS TO TRY TO
MITIGATE A LIFETIME SENTENCE FOR
R. KELLY, SAYING THIS IN PART IS
WHAT CAUSED HIM TO BE WHO HE
WAS, AND THAT A FORENSIC
PSYCHIATRIST DETERMINED HE WAS
NOT A PEDOPHILE, BUT IT WAS JUST
A RESULT OF THE ABUSE.
BUT IN SOME, HE WAS CONVICTED OF
NINE COUNTS HERE, VERY SERIOUS,
SERIOUS FELONI